ahora vamos a contabilizar la misma
serie de eventos pero en lugar de verlo
desde el punto de vista del efectivo lo
veremos sobre la base devengada y la
idea detrás de la contabilidad sobre
base devengada es comparar las ganancias
y los gastos de realizar el servicio
esta captura la actividad de la empresa
en lugar de capturar solo cuando entra
usar el dinero vamos a ver qué significa
en el primer mes ustedes sirvieron en un
evento en donde su costo fue de 100 el
cliente les pagó 200 dólares por sus
servicios y voy a hacer la contabilidad
de base devengada aquí en medio de estas
columnas ese es el efectivo y este es el
devengado
ustedes proveyeron el servicio y
obtuviera 200 dólares por sus servicios
200 dólares en el dinero recibido y los
gastos que tuvieron relacionado con este
servicio en el primer mes fue de 100
dólares
lo vamos a escribir aquí
100 dólares en gastos por lo que nuestra
ganancia es de 100 dólares para el
primer mes el análisis de efectivo y el
de base devengada son iguales y de nuevo
tenemos 100 dólares en efectivo ahora
analicemos el segundo mes se atendió un
evento donde el costo fue de 200 dólares
y usted y su cliente acordaron que se
pagaría 400 dólares el siguiente mes
ahora se pone interesante ya que ustedes
realizaron el servicio ese mes y este
servicio vale 400 dólares desde el punto
de vista de la contabilidad sobre base
devengada ustedes dirían que ustedes
recibieron 400 dólares aunque el cliente
aún no les ha pagado esto ustedes aún no
han recibido el efectivo por parte del
cliente y la forma en la que ustedes
contabilizan esto es que en su hoja de
balance ponen que a ustedes se les debe
400 dólares cuentas por cobrar esto es
lo que otras personas les deben a
ustedes ustedes van a recibir esto de
otras personas es un bien las otras
personas tienen la obligación de
pagarles a ustedes así que tienen una
cuenta por cobrar de 400 dólares
cuando les hacen el pago esta cantidad
pasará de cuentas por cobrar a efectivo
y ponemos que el costo fue de 200
dólares
aquí lo escribimos el costo fue de 200
dólares y aquí tenemos el pago del
servicio como los gastos de ese mes y
ahora la ganancia nos queda de 200
dólares
qué es una mejor reflexión de lo que se
hizo en ese mes ahora la realidad es que
ese mes ustedes tuvieron que gastar de
su bolsillo 200 dólares y aún no reciben
su pago por lo que en efectivo lo que
tienen igual que en la otra columna
menos 100 dólares de efectivo ahora
vayamos al tercer mes aquí ustedes
reciben 400 dólares del cliente del mes
anterior en el modo basado en efectivo
ustedes agregan eso a lo que ya tienen
anteriormente pero aquí ya lo teníamos
en nuestras cuentas por cobrar pero
ahora que se tiene en efectivo esos 400
dólares desaparece de las cuentas por
cobrar y se va hacia el efectivo tenemos
400 dólares que pagó el cliente del mes
pasado y también si tiene un avance de
200 dólares de un cliente al que hay que
servir el siguiente mes no se dio ningún
servicio en el mes 3 y debido a esto se
tiene cero en el dinero recibido y
también se tiene cero en los gastos la
forma en la que tomamos en cuenta esos
400 dólares que recibimos
es que bueno las cuentas por cobrar
quedan en ceros
esto va hacia el efectivo por lo que
nuestros menos 100 dólares al agregarles
los 400 dólares que recibimos vamos a
tener positivo 300 dólares y la forma en
la que tomamos en cuenta estos 200
dólares de adelantado es ponerlos como
ingresos diferidos tenemos el efectivo
aquí pasamos de menos 100 agregamos 400
nos quedan 300 tenemos otros 200 en
efectivo de adelanto o lo que en
efectivo tendremos 500 dólares pero
realmente no hemos tenido ninguna
recaudación esos 200 dólares es su pago
en efectivo por adelantado ingresos
diferidos ya que es un pago que estamos
refiriendo a otro período esto nos lo
vamos a ganar en un futuro nosotros
estamos obligados a dar ese servicio y
en el cuarto mes realizamos el servicio
así que en el mes cuarto lo ponemos como
recaudación los 200 dólares y vemos que
nuestro costo fue de 100 dólares durante
ese mes nuestros gastos de 100 dólares
por lo que en el mes cuarto nos ganamos
100 dólares recuerda que aquí tenemos
que quitar 100 dólares de nuestro
efectivo por lo que aquí nos queda 400
dólares de efectivo ya sea que lo hagan
con base en el efectivo o con respecto a
la contabilidad sobre base devengada
vamos a tener exactamente la misma
cantidad de efectivo pero lo que es más
interesante aún es como las ganancias se
relacionan en cada periodo y hablaremos
con más detalle al respecto en el
siguiente vídeo